bei geimpften ist es so dass man oft
schon symptome hat bevor man überhaupt
ansteckend ist weil die impfung führt
dazu dass sozusagen der körper sehr
schnell reagiert noch wenig viruslast
und dann erst kommen die wehren und dann
stark die viruslast es ist ein schönes
beispiel dass wir von anfang an der
krise ich sag das jetzt mal klar
deutliche schritte von dilettanten
blendern und scharlatanen informiert
werden wir haben massiv zu kämpfen
gehabt mit diesen schwer versterben dass
sie widersprächen den zahlen des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums ist auf
homepage ist es die leipziger analyse
und diese experten die ich als
dilettanten bezeichnung das war das
nenne ich auch lauterbach dazu die haben
oft knallharte interessenskonflikte
lauterbach hat in seiner karriere schon
sehr viele gefährliche medikamente
gefeatured die dann vom markt genommen
worden sind ja sehr fragwürdig